expertement je remercie d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france alors on a
l'impression que la stratégie change un
petit peu avec des actions plus
radicales en gardant les mêmes objectifs
qu'elles vont être ce genre de ce type
d'action prévue aujourd'hui justement
alors je pourrais vous parler de rouen
qui va organiser des rassemblements par
rapport aux six de ces vaisseaux en ce
moment il est aussi à annecy à un
rassemblement régional d'action de
désobéissance civile donc paris va
organiser un camp climat aussi
aujourd'hui qui a dû commencer à cette
heure ci et il ya les villes de tanger
de la roche sur yon qui organise des
actions de désobéissance civile aussi
alors les gouvernements sont ciblés mais
pas seulement ce sont surtout les
entreprises 1 qui sont dans le viseur
vous leur demandez un changement de
méthode trouver des alternatives pour
améliorer le climat
ces revendications sont elles réelles
sont elle réalisable surtout ben on
espère on demande à chaque emprunt aux
entreprises polluantes de changer les
choses pour nous aider à avoir un avenir
justement et on espère que on va réussir
à faire changer les choses alors greta
feinberg 1
qui est un petit peu voilà à la tête de
ce mouvement a repris du service après
une année sabbatique
est ce que c'est une motivation
supplémentaire pour vous bah oui les
choses reviennent petit à petit comme on
espère le 15 mars et on espère que ça
reprendra de l'ampleur comme ça a été
les autres fois great attenberg du coup
a refait à est revenu pour pour relancer
le mouvement un peu donc c'est une bonne
chose
on est en pleine crise du corona virus
comment est ce que vous vous voyez les
choses on vous avait parlé de
désobéissance civile non violente
notamment dans certaines régions est ce
que c'est ce type d'action que vous
privilégiez oui alors les actions se
font dans le respect total des des
gestes barrières et des ddv des
gestes-barrières avec port du masque et
c est vraiment les actions désobéissance
civile se font en plein air donc il n'y
a aucun risque de ce côté là est
vraiment tout est fait pour respecter
toutes les mesures sanitaires et tout ce
qu'il faut
depuis la création du mouvement en 2018
est ce que vous avez senti une prise de
conscience de la part des gouvernements
des entreprises
au contraire rien n'a changé une prise
de conscience plutôt du grand public par
rapport à pendant leur confinement avec
toutes les nouvelles qui nous sont
arrivés il ya vraiment une prise de
conscience de ce côté là après les
dirigeants le savent ça c'est sûr on
peut pas ne pas être au courant
maintenant il faut faire quelque chose
il faut passer à l'action
on attend de voir ça merci beaucoup alex
martin d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes membre du
mouvement
youtube est